NICU.
I just saw your Instagram story says how impressive.
How on earth did you get a reservation there? Lucky.
I guess that's a wonderful race. Don't tell me, don't tell me,
let me guess Patagonia and Keela.
If you're so sad or compliment was sufficient. Kevin. Hello, Raj.
Nice glasses. How the hell are ya?
Paul has mistaken me for this Dick Russia sawn.
It seems logical because Raj also works in infra.
And in fact it's the same exact thing I do.
And he also has a pension for Patagonia vests and Gucci glasses. Roger,
and I even go to the same Cooper cafe and Palo Alto.
Although I order a slightly more expensive drink.
How's the Gemini project going? It's uh, it's all right. Oh, that's interesting.
That's not, it's not great. Oh, well, you know? Hmm. How's uh,
how's Cecilia. She's uh, she's a great girl. Yes,
I'm very lucky. Hey Paul, congratulations on the Leo project.
Thank you, Jimmy. Listen, Paul bouldering. Sure. When,
how about Friday? No, can do I got an eight 30 Rez at Sasol.
It's got a great C or chin. So each Friday night,
how do you swing that? I bet he's lying.
New keys. What do you think?
Whoa, look at that.
Picked it up on Amazon yesterday. Good switches.
Their blues and the O rings or point twos. That's very cool when to kill,
but that's nothing. Look at this.
That is really nice. That makes Brown wood plant fours.
What do you think? Jesus,
this is really super. How does the name it? Like you get so tasteful?
I can't believe that Brian prefers Sam B as keys to mine, but wait,
you ain't seen nothing yet.
Obsidian black and green switches.
Impressive. Very nice.
Let's see John Elton's keys
look at that said lock like coloring, but tasteful actuation force.
Oh my God. The keys aren't even labeled
NICU, something wrong. You're sweating.
Okay. So you're telling me, I just opened the app. I type in how long I, uh,
how often and what color it is. And at the end of the week,
it's going to tell me what medical conditions I have. Yeah.
And if you get the premium version,
you'll actually also find out how long you have to live. Wow.
That is really nice. So this one's premium. Yeah.
So if you actually take a look and if the color turns red,
that means you have until.
[Inaudible].